THAT FLORIDA RESERVE TODAY.
THEY NEED A MAJOR BREAK IN THIS
CASE.
ARE THEY CLOSE TO IT?
WE'LL SEE.
BUT THERE'S ALSO SOMETHING I
WANT TO TALK TO YOU ABOUT THAT
EVERY SINGLE AMERICAN NEEDS TO
HEAR.
OKAY?
AND I WANT YOU TO LISTEN RIGHT
NOW BECAUSE THIS IS REALLY
IMPORTANT.
THERE'S A CLEAR AND PRESENT
DANGER TO OUR DEMOCRACY TONIGHT.
RIGHT NOW.
WE'RE IN VERY REAL DANGER OF
LOSING OUR DEMOCRACY.
WE'RE LEARNING TONIGHT JUST HOW
CLOSE WE CAME TO THAT AND HOW
SCLOES WE ARE RIGHT NOW.
THE FORMER GUY ATTEMPTED A COUP.
HE TRIED TO STRONGARM THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT TO HELP HIM
AND HE IS STILL AT IT TODAY,
TRYING TO SOW DOUBT ABOUT THE
ELECTION THAT HE LOST.
NOW, I WANT YOU TO THINK ABOUT
THIS.
NINE TIMES.
NINE TIMES THE THEN PRESIDENT
TRIED TO GET THE D.O.J. TO
UNDERMINE THE RESULT OF OUR FREE
AND FAIR ELECTION.
YOU KNOW, THE ONE JOE BIDEN WON
WITH MORE THAN 81 MILLION VOTES?
THE ONE THE FORMER GUY LOST.
HE AND HIS ALLIES TRIED TO PULL
OFF A COUP.
AND NOW THE SENATE HAS THE
RECEIPTS.
DEMOCRATS ON THE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE FINDING THE THEN
PRESIDENT DIRECTLY ASKED THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT NINE TIMES TO
UNDERMINE THE ELECTION RESULT,
BEGINNING IN MID DECEMBER AND
CONTINUING THROUGH JANUARY 3rd,
JUST THREE DAYS BEFORE THE
VIOLENT INSURRECTION AT THE
CAPITOL.
HE TRIED TO REPLACE THE THEN
ACTING ATTORNEY GENERAL BECAUSE
HE WOULDN'T PLAY ALONG.
>> HIS OWN COUNSEL, PAT
CIPOLLONE, BASICALLY SAID IT WAS
A MURDER-SUICIDE PACT THAT HE
WAS CONSIDERING AND THAT THERE
WERE GOING TO BE RESIGNATIONS
ALL ACROSS THE COUNTRY IF HE DID
ANYTHING THIS RADICAL.
>> AND THE GOP, WELL, THEY SAY
HEY, IT DIDN'T WORK SO, YOU
KNOW, IT'S ALL GOOD.
DIDN'T WORK.
REPUBLICAN SENATOR CHUCK
GRASSLEY'S OFFICE ISSUING A GOP
REBUTTAL, CALLING THE FORMER
PRESIDENT'S OUTRAGEOUS ACTIONS
NOT UNREASONABLE.
>> THE PRESIDENT REJECTED IT.
THE PRESIDENT DID THE RIGHT
THING.
HOW DOES THAT CREATE ANY SORT OF
PROBLEM?
>> OH, SHOCKING UPDATE FOR YOU
RIGHT NOW.
NOT COINCIDENTALLY, NOT AT ALL.
SENATOR GRASSLEY IS SET TO JOIN
THE FORMER PRESIDENT AT A RALLY
IN IOWA THIS SATURDAY.
YEAH.
LIKE I SAID, NOT IN THE PAST,
STILL GOING ON RIGHT NOW.
AN ATTORNEY FOR THE FORMER
PRESIDENT INSTRUCTING SOME OF
HIS FORMER AIDES NOT TO COMPLY
WITH SUBPOENAS FROM THE JANUARY
6th COMMITTEE.
THEY HAVE UNTIL MIDNIGHT.
THAT IS ACCORDING TO THE
"WASHINGTON POST."
THE COMMITTEE STILL LOOKING FOR
TRUMP'S FORMER COMMUNICATIONSSC
SERVE HIM WITH A SUBPOENA.
THEY WANT TO FIND OUT WHAT HE
KNOWS ABOUT VIDEOS LIKE THIS
ONE.
>> GO HOME.
WE LOVE YOU.
YOU'RE VERY SPECIAL.
YOU'VE SEEN WHAT HAPPENS.
YOU SEE THE WAY OTHERS ARE
TREATED THAT ARE SO BAD AND SO
EVIL.
I KNOW HOW YOU FEEL.
>> WE LOVE YOU.
WE LOVE YOU.
THE COMMITTEE FIRING OFF A NEW
ROUND OF SUBPOENAS TONIGHT
FOCUSING ON THE STOP THE STEAL
GROUP AND ITS INVOLVEMENT IN THE
PLANNING OF THE RALLY BEFORE THE
INSURRECTION AT THE CAPITOL.
THAT AS CNN HAS REVIEWED MORE
THAN 2,000 PAGES OF COURT
RECORDS SHOWING RUDY GIULIANI
AND COMPANY, THAT THEY DID NEXT
TO NOTHING TO ACTUALLY CHECK OUT
THEIR BOGUS CLAIMS OF
NON-EXISTENT ELECTION FRAUD.
DEBUNKED CLAIMS OF ELECTION
RIGGING AND TIES TO ANTIFA, PUT
IN FRONT OF A NATIONAL AUDIENCE
DURING HIS CLOWN SHOW OF
CONSPIRACY THEORIES AND LIES
WHILE APPARENTLY MOPPING HAIR
DYE OFF OF HIS FACE.
AND THEN THERE'S TODAY'S HEARING
ON THE ARIZONA FRAUDIT.
JUST MORE EVIDENCE THAT ALL OF
THIS IS ABOUT PLANTING THE SEEDS
OF DOUBT, AND IT'S HAPPENING
RIGHT NOW, RIGHT UNDER OUR
NOSES.
>> BIDEN --
>> MY QUESTION, MR. BIGGS.
I'M HAPPY TO YIELD TO YOU FOR
THAT.
WHO WON THE ELECTION IN ARIZONA,
DONALD TRUMP --
>> WE DON'T KNOW.
BECAUSE AS THE AUDIT
DEMONSTRATES VERY CLEARLY, MR.
RASKIN, THERE ARE A LOT OF
ISSUES WITH THIS ELECTION THAT
TOOK PLACE.
>> WE DON'T KNOW?
BRO.
WE DON'T KNOW.
JOE BIDEN IN THE FRAUDIT GOT
MORE VOTES.
THAT WAS THE FRAUDIT RESULTS.
JUST LAST BWEEK THE FORMER
PRESIDENT CLAIMED THE FRAUDIT
PROVED HE WON.
EXACTLY THE OPPOSITE OF WHAT IT
PROVED.
HE LOST.
THINK ABOUT WHAT HAPPENS IF THE
GOP WINS IN THE MIDTERMS.
THAT'S THE END OF CONGRESSIONAL
HEARINGS OF THE BIG LIE.
THE END OF ANY REAL EFFORTS TO
STOP THE NATIONWIDE ASSAULT ON
THE RIGHT TO VOTE.
DID YOU HEAR ME?
MAYBE YOU'RE NOT PAYING
ATTENTION NOW.
MAYBE YOU DIDN'T HEAR ME.
CALL YOUR FRIENDS.
TEXT THEM.
OR SOCIAL MEDIA, WHATEVER IT IS.
JUMP IN THEIR DMs AND TELL THEM.
YOU'D BETTER PAY ATTENTION.
BECAUSE THE THREAT IS VERY REAL.
THE GOP STILL KOWTOWING TO I
ADISGRACED TWICE-IMPEACHED
ONE-TERM EX-PRESIDENT.
NIKKI HALEY TELLING THE "WALL
STREET JOURNAL" THEY NEED HIM IN
THE GOP.
MIKE PENCE TRYING TO BLAME THE
MEDIA FOR THE ATTACK BY VIOLENT
RIOTERS, TRUMP SUPPORTERS, WHO
SAID THEY WANTED TO HANG HIM, AN
ATTACK THAT FORCED HIM TO RUN
FOR HIS LIFE WITH HIS FAMILY.
>> HANG MIKE PENCE!
HANG MIKE PENCE!
>> SO REMEMBER WHAT HAPPENED ON
JANUARY 6th.
OKAY?
EVEN TRUMP LOYALISTS SAW HOW
DANGEROUS IT WAS.
LINDSEY GRAHAM SAW IT.
>> I KNOW THE MEDIA WANTS TO
DISTRACT FROM THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION'S FAILED AGENDA
BY FOCUSING ON ONE DAY IN
JANUARY.
THEY WANT TO USE THAT ONE DAY TO
TRY AND DEMEAN THE CHARACTER AND
INTENTIONS OF 74 MILLION
AMERICANS WHO WERE --
>> OBVIOUSLY, THAT WAS THE
FORMER VICE PRESIDENT SAYING
THAT JANUARY 6th WAS NO BIG
DEAL.
BUT HERE IS LINDSEY GRAHAM NOW.
>> TRUMP AND I, WE'VE HAD A HELL
OF A JOURNEY.
I HATE IT TO END THIS WAY.
OH MY GOD, I HATE IT.
FROM MY POINT OF VIEW HE'S BEEN
A CONSEQUENTIAL PRESIDENT.
BUT TODAY, FIRST THING YOU'LL
SEE.
ALL I CAN SAY IS COUNT ME OUT.
ENOUGH IS ENOUGH.
>> KEVIN McCARTHY SAW IT AS
WELL.
>> THE PRESIDENT BEARS
RESPONSIBILITY FOR WEDNESDAY'S
ATTACK ON CONGRESS BY MOB
RIOTERS.
HE SHOULD HAVE IMMEDIATELY
DENOUNCED THE MOB WHEN HE SAW
WHAT WAS UNFOLDING.
>> MITCH McCONNELL SAW IT.
>> THERE'S NO QUESTION.
NONE.
THAT PRESIDENT TRUMP IS
PRACTICALLY AND MORALLY
RESPONSIBLE FOR PROVOKING THE
EVENTS OF THE DAY.
NO QUESTION ABOUT IT.
THE PEOPLE WHO STORMED THIS
BUILDING BELIEVED THEY WERE
ACTING ON THE WISHES AND
INSTRUCTIONS OF THEIR PRESIDENT.
AND HAVING THAT BELIEF WAS A
FORESEEABLE CONSEQUENCE OF THE
GROWING CRESCENDO OF FALSE
STATEMENTS, CONSPIRACY THEORIES,
AND RECKLESS HYPERBOLE WHICH THE
DEFEATED PRESIDENT KEPT SHOUTING
INTO THE LARGEST MEGAPHONE ON
PLANET EARTH.
>> WOW.
IT'S ALMOST LIKE THAT NIGHT HE
TOOK TRUTH SERUM.
RIGHT?
ALL OF THEM.
AND WHERE ARE THEY NOW?
WHERE ARE THEY NOW?
THE BIG LIE IS ALL ABOUT LAYING
THE GROUNDWORK FOR THE NEXT
TIME.
THAT'S WHY I SAY PAY ATTENTION
BECAUSE MAKE NO MISTAKE, THE
THREAT IS GATHERING AGAIN.
WE DIDN'T REALLY KNOW UNTIL ALL
THESE REPORTS STARTED COMING
OUT.
AND THERE ARE GOING TO BE MORE.
DIDN'T KNOW HOW CLOSE WE CAME
THEN.
BUT WE'D BETTER OPEN OUR EYES
AND SEE HOW CLOSE WE ARE NOW.
LOOK AT WHAT'S HAPPENING AROUND
THE COUNTRY.
WITH ALL THE ELECTION LAWS
RESTRICTING THE RIGHTS FOR
PEOPLE